- ברוכים השבים לסדרה "הבנת מידע
וחישוב קוונטי".
שמי John Watrous, ואני המנהל הטכני
של החינוך ב-IBM Quantum.
זהו השיעור השני בסדרה. אם עדיין לא
צפיתם בשיעור הראשון, כדאי לבדוק אותו.
אנחנו נבנה ישירות על מה שדיברנו עליו
בשיעור הראשון, אז חשוב שיהיה לכם
הבנה של החומר הזה לפני שנכנסים לשיעור הזה.
כמו כן, שימו לב שהסדרה
כוללת תוכן של ספר לימוד בנוסף לסרטונים, ואפשר למצוא קישור
לתוכן של ספר הלימוד
בתיאור הסרטון. זהו שיעור שתיים של
יחידה אחת בסדרה.
יחידה אחת מכסה את היסודות
של מידע קוונטי.
בשיעור הקודם, דיברנו על מידע קוונטי בהקשר של מערכות בודדות, כלומר שיש לנו מערכת אחת
שמאחסנת מידע
ואנחנו מתארים איך
היא עובדת בבידוד.
הקדשנו זמן לא מבוטל
למידע קלאסי, בעיקר כדי לבסס נקודת ייחוס וכדי להדגיש את
הדמיון המתמטי
בין מידע קוונטי וקלאסי.
ראינו גם איך מצבים קוונטיים יכולים להיות מיוצגים על ידי וקטורים, ספציפית וקטורים עם
רשומות של מספרים מרוכבים ונורמה אוקלידית השווה לאחד,
ודנו במדידות בסיס סטנדרטי
ובפעולות אוניטריות.
בשיעור הזה, אנחנו הולכים להרחיב את
הנקודת מבט שלנו למערכות מרובות, שכל אחת מהן מסוגלת
לאחסן מידע קוונטי.
זה לא פשוט עניין של לומר שכל מערכת בודדת
עובדת כמו שדיברנו בפעם הקודמת, יש מובן שבו השלם
גדול מסכום חלקיו, וזה נכון גם לגבי
מידע קלאסי כשהסתברויות מעורבות.
מערכות מרובות יכולות
לקיים אינטראקציה זו עם זו ויכולות להיות מתואמות
זו עם זו למשל, ובהקשר הקוונטי, זה כולל את האפשרות
שהמערכות שזורות, מונח שאולי
שמעתם עליו בעבר.
שזירה היא תופעה מאוד
חשובה במידע קוונטי ויהיה לנו עוד הרבה מה לומר עליה ככל שהסדרה ממשיכה.
יש עיקרון פשוט, עם זאת, שנותן לנו די הרבה אחיזה לחשוב על ולהבין
מידע קוונטי עבור מערכות מרובות,
וזה שאנחנו תמיד יכולים
לקחת שתי מערכות או יותר ולשים אותן ביחד או סתם מבחינה מושגית
לחשוב עליהן ביחד
ולראות אותן כאילו הן יוצרות
מערכת מורכבת אחת.
וכשאנחנו חושבים על מערכת
מורכבת כזו, כאילו היא מערכת אחת, אנחנו מכירים בכך שהיא חייבת להיות מתוארת באופן שעקבי
עם כל מה שלמדנו
בשיעור הקודם על מערכות בודדות.
נראה איך זה עובד
ואיך התיאור של מידע קוונטי
ממערכות מרובות צומח בצורה די טבעית מהאופן שבו זה עובד למערכות בודדות
על בסיס העיקרון היחיד הזה. הנה סקירה כללית של השיעור וזה במקרה זהה לסקירה של השיעור הקודם,
אבל הפעם המיקוד שלנו
יהיה על מערכות מרובות במקום מערכות בודדות.
בדיוק כמו שעשינו בשיעור הקודם ומבדיוק אותן סיבות, אנחנו הולכים להתחיל עם
מידע קלאסי.
שוב, נראה
דמיון קרוב מאוד בין האופן שבו מידע קוונטי
וקלאסי עובדים ברמה מתמטית.
בדרך כלל לא נתמקד כל כך
הרבה במידע קלאסי ולא נתחיל כל שיעור בסדרה עם מידע קלאסי ככה.
שיעורים הבאים ייטו להתמקד הרבה יותר באופן בלעדי במידע וחישוב קוונטי.
אבל כאן בהתחלה
זו גישה הגיונית וזה חוזר לרעיון שחשיבה על מידע קלאסי
יכולה לשמש כמקור הכוונה יקר ערך להבנת מידע קוונטי.
אנחנו גם הולכים לדון
במושג החשוב של מכפלה טנזורית בחלק
הזה של השיעור.
מכפלות טנזוריות הן קריטיות במידע קוונטי, אבל הן עולות גם
בהקשר הקלאסי.
אחר כך נעבור למידע קוונטי ובדומה לשיעור הקודם נדון במצבים קוונטיים,
מדידות בסיס סטנדרטי,
ופעולות אוניטריות הפעם
עבור מערכות מרובות.
נתחיל בלדבר
על מצבים קלאסיים של מערכות מרובות.
היזכרו מהשיעור הקודם
שמצב קלאסי של מערכת הוא
קונפיגורציה של אותה מערכת שאפשר לזהות ולתאר
באופן חד-משמעי
ללא שום אי ודאות או שגיאה. ובמונחים מתמטיים, כשאנחנו מתייחסים לקבוצת מצבים קלאסית,
אנחנו פשוט מתכוונים לקבוצה סופית ולא ריקה.
נתחיל את הדיון שלנו
על מערכות מרובות בהנחה שיש לנו
רק שתי מערכות X ו-Y.
ל-X יש קבוצה כלשהי של מצבים קלאסיים שנקרא לה סיגמא בדיוק
כמו בשיעור הקודם, ול-Y יש קבוצה כלשהי של מצבים קלאסיים
שנקרא לה גמא. הקבוצות סיגמא וגמא
יכולות להיות אותה קבוצה או שהן יכולות להיות שונות,
אבל אנחנו נותנים להן שמות שונים, לא רק בגלל שהן
יכולות להיות קבוצות שונות, אלא גם כי זה יעזור
לנו לשמור על הדברים ברורים אם ניתן להן שמות שונים.
נגלה שזה
די קל להכליל את כל הדיון הזה משתי מערכות לכל מספר של מערכות, אבל
על ידי התחלה עם שתי מערכות,
אנחנו יכולים להתמקד ברעיונות הבסיסיים בלי להסתבך בפרטים.
עכשיו, דמיינו שאנחנו
שמים את X ו-Y זה לצד זה עם X בצד שמאל ו-Y בצד ימין, ואנחנו רואים את שתי המערכות האלה ביחד
כאילו הן יוצרות מערכת מורכבת אחת.
כדי לתת למערכת החדשה הזו שם, אנחנו יכולים לכתוב אותה כזוג
סדור ככה, או שאנחנו יכולים פשוט לשים
את שתי האותיות זו ליד זו ככה.
שניהם נפוצים ואנחנו
יכולים לבחור מה שנרצה או מה שיותר נוח.
בכל מקרה, נקרא לזה XY.
שאלה מאוד טבעית
לשאול בנקודה הזו היא מהם המצבים הקלאסיים של המערכת המורכבת החדשה הזו XY?
והתשובה לשאלה הזו היא שקבוצת המצבים הקלאסית של XY היא המכפלה הקרטזית של
שתי קבוצות המצבים הקלאסיות,
סיגמא וגמא, שאפשר
לראות מוגדרות ממש כאן.
ברגע נתון, ל-X יש מצב קלאסי כלשהו
שהוא איבר של סיגמא, ול-Y יש מצב קלאסי כלשהו
שהוא איבר של גמא,
ואנחנו פשוט חושבים
על שני המצבים האלה ביחד כאילו הם יוצרים מצב אחד, וזה בדיוק המושג
שהמכפלה הקרטזית לוכדת. יש לנו שני איברים,
אחד מכל אחת מהקבוצות שלנו, ואנחנו רוצים לחשוב על
שני האיברים האלה ביחד
כאילו הם יוצרים איבר אחד
מקבוצה אחת.
ליתר דיוק, יש כאן הנחה והיא שאנחנו יודעים
איזו מהמערכות שלנו היא X ואיזו היא Y,
ואין בלבול ביניהן. זה לא חשוב שX נמצאת פיזית בצד
שמאל ו-Y בצד ימין,
אלא ששתי
המערכות ניתנות להבחנה ושהחלטנו
לסדר אותן ככה רק כדי שנוכל לשמור
על סדר מי זה מי.
הנה דוגמה מאוד פשוטה שבה סיגמא היא האלפבית הבינארי וגמא היא הקבוצה
שמכילה את ארבעת סמלי הקלפים.
אם X מאחסנת ערך בינארי ו-Y מאחסנת אחד מארבעת סמלי הקלפים, אז יש שמונה
מצבים קלאסיים אפשריים
של הזוג XY, שאפשר
לראות אותם מפורטים ממש כאן.
עבור יותר משתי מערכות, זה מוכלל בצורה ישירה.
בפרט אם X1 עד Xn הן מערכות עם קבוצות מצבים
קלאסיות סיגמא אחד עד סיגמא n בהתאמה.
אז אם אנחנו מדמיינים קיבוץ
של n המערכות ביחד ורואים אותן כמערכת אחת, קבוצת המצבים הקלאסית ניתנת
על ידי המכפלה הקרטזית
של n קבוצות המצבים הקלאסיות
סיגמא אחד עד סיגמא n.
כפי שאפשר לראות ממש כאן על המסך. את המכפלה הקרטזית
אפשר להגדיר ככה עבור כל מספר של קבוצות.
לדוגמה, אם יש לנו שלוש מערכות וכולן חולקות את האלפבית הבינארי כקבוצת המצבים הקלאסית שלהן, כלומר במילים אחרות יש לנו שלושה ביטים,
אז יש שמונה
מצבים קלאסיים אפשריים של שלושת הביטים הנראים
ביחד כמערכת אחת ואפשר לראות אותם מפורטים ממש כאן.
כל מערכת באופן בודד יכולה
להיות במצב אפס או אחד, ואנחנו עוברים על כל
השילובים האפשריים.
n-יית של מצבים קלאסיים יכולה לחלופין להיכתב כמחרוזת שבה אנחנו מורידים את
הסוגריים ואת הפסיק כמו שרואים כאן.
וזה הגיוני במיוחד כשאנחנו חושבים על
מצבים קלאסיים כסמלים כמו בדוגמה הנפוצה מאוד
של האלפבית הבינארי
שאנחנו חוזרים אליה שוב ושוב. לפעמים זה מאוד נוח לעשות את זה וזה נוטה להפוך
את הביטויים שלנו לפשוטים יותר
ופחות עמוסים. המושג של מחרוזת הוא למעשה מפורמל
במונחים מתמטיים דרך מכפלות קרטזיות,
אז זה באמת רק
סימון חלופי ולא משהו שונה מבחינה מושגית.
כדוגמה, נניח שיש לנו
10 ביטים X1 עד X10.
זה אומר שקבוצת המצבים הקלאסית של 10 הביטים ביחד,
שאפשר לחשוב עליה באופן טבעי כרגיסטר של 10 ביטים
במחשב למשל,
היא המכפלה הקרטזית פי עשר
של האלפבית הבינארי עם עצמו.
ואם אנחנו כותבים את המצבים האלה כמחרוזות, הם נראים כמו שרואים ממש
כאן, יש 1,024 מהם,
אז כמובן שהם לא כולם מפורטים כאן. שלוש הנקודות האלה ממש כאן
אמורות לציין שיש דפוס שאפשר להסיק
ובתקווה שהבנתם את הרעיון. עכשיו יש מוסכמה
שאנחנו הולכים לעקוב אחריה לגבי סידור האיברים
של קבוצות מכפלה קרטזית,
וחשוב להבהיר
את זה לצורך ייצוג גם מצבים הסתברותיים וגם מצבים קוונטיים כוקטורים.
המוסכמה היא שאנחנו
מסדרים את האיברים של קבוצות מכפלה
קרטזית לקסיקוגרפית, שזה בעצם אומר
סדר מילוני.
ליתר דיוק, אנחנו מתחילים מההנחה שלכל אחת מהקבוצות הבודדות שאנחנו לוקחים מהן את המכפלה הקרטזית כבר יש סדר משלה
ואנחנו חושבים על
n-יית נתונה או מחרוזת כאילו היא מילה ואנחנו
מסדרים אותן אלפביתית.
דרך אחרת לומר את זה היא שהמיקומים בתוך
n-יית או מחרוזת יורדים בחשיבותם
משמאל לימין,
בדיוק כמו כשאנחנו כותבים מספרים באמצעות הספרות אפס עד תשע.
הנה דוגמה שנועדה
להבהיר את זה.
אם אנחנו לוקחים את המכפלה הקרטזית בין הקבוצות שמכילות
אחד, שתיים ושלוש ואת האלפבית הבינארי, אנחנו מקבלים קבוצה שמכילה שישה איברים
וכאן הם מפורטים בסדר
שתואר.
כל האיברים עם
אחד במיקום הראשון באים לפני כל האיברים עם שתיים במיקום הראשון והם באים לפני כל האיברים
עם שלוש במיקום הראשון. וכשני איברים
מסכימים במיקום הראשון, אנחנו חוזרים לסדר
במיקום השני.
אז זה הסדר שאנחנו
משתמשים בו למכפלות קרטזיות.
שימו לב שכשאנחנו משתמשים במוסכמה הזו וכותבים n-ייתות כמחרוזות, אנחנו רואים דפוסים מאוד מוכרים.
לדוגמה, המכפלה הקרטזית של
האלפבית הבינארי עם עצמו מסודרת כמו שרואים כאן,
ואפשר לחשוב על המחרוזות האלה כמסודרות מספרית אם לוקחים את המחרוזות
כקידודים בינאריים של מספרים שלמים אי-שליליים
וזה מוכלל
לכל אורך מחרוזת. נעבור למצבים הסתברותיים, אנחנו כבר יודעים מהשיעור הקודם
שמצב הסתברותי משייך הסתברות לכל מצב קלאסי
של מערכת נתונה.
אם יש לנו מערכת מורכבת שבה לקחנו שתי מערכות או יותר ואנחנו רואים אותן באופן קולקטיבי כאילו הן יוצרות מערכת אחת
כמו שרק דנו,
אז מצב הסתברותי
של המערכת המורכבת הזו חייב להקצות הסתברויות לאיברים של המכפלה הקרטזית
של המערכות הבודדות,
קבוצות מצבים קלאסיות. זה בגלל שזו
קבוצת המצבים הקלאסית של המערכת המורכבת.
למשל, בהנחה
ש-X ו-Y הם ביטים, יש לנו את הדוגמה הזו של
מצב הסתברותי של XY.
ההסתברות ששני
הביטים הם אפס היא חצי וההסתברות ששני
הביטים הם אחד היא חצי, ואז שני הביטים אף פעם לא חולקים.
זהו מצב הסתברותי תקף של XY, ואנחנו יכולים לחלופין
לכתוב אותו כוקטור
כמו שרואים כאן וכאן אפשר לראות שאנחנו
עוקבים אחרי המוסכמה שתיארתי לפני רגע לסידור המצבים הקלאסיים האלה.
זו דוגמה של
מצב הסתברותי שבו X ו-Y מתואמים, וזה המובן שבו השלם
גדול מסכום חלקיו. כפי שהצעתי קודם, זה לא פשוט שיש לנו
מצב הסתברותי
של X ומצב הסתברותי של Y ואנחנו שמים אותם ביחד, אלא קודם אנחנו שמים
את המערכות ביחד
ואז אנחנו חושבים על
מצבים הסתברותיים של המערכת המורכבת.
כדי להיות יותר מדויקים לגבי
מתאמים בין מערכות. אנחנו מתחילים בהגדרת
המושג של אי-תלות, שזה בעצם
העדר מתאם.
כאן דרך אגב, המונח אי-תלות מתייחס
לאי-תלות סטטיסטית בניגוד לאי-תלות ליניארית
של וקטורים למשל.
זה מושג יסודי בתורת
ההסתברות והסטטיסטיקה.
אם יש לנו שתי מערכות X ו-Y ויש לנו מצב הסתברותי
כלשהו של XY בראש, אז אנחנו אומרים ש-X ו-Y הם בלתי תלויים.
אם הנוסחה שאתם
רואים כאן נכונה לכל בחירה של מצבים קלאסיים
a ו-b של X ו-Y.
דרך אחת לפרש את
התנאי הזה של אי-תלות היא שהוא אומר שההסתברות ש-X יהיה באיזשהו מצב קלאסי אחד
וההסתברות ש-Y יהיה באיזה מצב קלאסי אחר אין להן שום
קשר אחת לשנייה.
אז, ללמוד באיזה מצב
אחת מהמערכות נמצאת לא משפיע על
ההסתברויות שמשויכות למצבים של המערכת האחרת.
אם אתם מדמיינים בחירה אקראית
של מצב קלאסי כלשהו של X לפי הליך כלשהו ואז בחירה אקראית
של מצב קלאסי כלשהו של Y
לפי הליך אחר שלא קשור בשום צורה
לזה של X, כמו למשל אם אדם אחד מטיל מטבע
ואדם אחר בחדר
אחר מטיל קובייה, אז זו הנוסחה
שתשתמשו בה כדי לקבל את ההסתברויות
לשילובים שונים
של מצבים שמופיעים. המטרה של ההגדרה היא שאי-תלות היא
כשהנוסחה תקפה.
כשאנחנו חושבים על מצבים הסתברותיים במונחי וקטורי הסתברות, יש ניסוח פשוט
של התנאי הזה
ספציפית אם יש לנו
מצב הסתברותי של XY, שאפשר לבטא אותו כוקטור
בסימון דיראק
כמו שרואים כאן. אז לומר ש-X ו-Y הם בלתי תלויים שקול לקיום
של שני וקטורי הסתברות,
קט Phi וקט Psi שדרך אגב אפשר
פשוט לקרוא להם Phi ו-Psi לקיצור המייצגים
מצבים הסתברותיים של X ו-Y בנפרד שמקיימים את השוויון הזה
שרואים כאן.
לכל בחירה של a ו-b, זה בעצם
ניסוח מחדש של ההגדרה במונחי וקטורים.
לדוגמה, הנה מצב הסתברותי
של זוג ביטים XY שעבורו X ו-Y הם בלתי תלויים.
התנאי הנדרש
לאי-תלות מתקיים עבור הוקטורים
שרואים כאן.
כלומר ההסתברות
לכל הגדרה אפשרית של שני הביטים ניתנת על ידי המכפלה של ההסתברויות המתאימות
של הביטים הבודדים.
למשל, ההסתברות ששני
הביטים יקבלו את הערך אפס שווה לשישית, שזה שווה לרבע
כפול שני שלישים,
ובאופן דומה לגבי
שלוש האפשרויות האחרות שאפשר לבדוק אחת אחת.
עבור המצב ההסתברותי שראינו קודם לכן מצד שני שבו
יש לנו שני ביטים שתמיד מסכימים ומקבלים את הערכים אפס ואחד
עם הסתברות של חצי
אין לנו אי-תלות וזו הסיבה שאנחנו אומרים שהביטים
מתואמים.
מתאם פשוט אומר
חוסר אי-תלות.
דרך פשוטה לטעון ששני
הביטים אינם בלתי תלויים היא להניח שהם כן ולהגיע לסתירה
ספציפית אם שני
הביטים היו בלתי תלויים, היו צריכים להתקיים
מספרים q0, q1, r0 ו-r1
שמייצגים הסתברויות
לשני הביטים הבודדים כך שהמשוואות
האלה כאן מתקיימות.
אלה ההסתברויות
שמגיעות מהוקטור שלנו ואלה
המשוואות שחייבות להתקיים מתנאי האי-תלות,
אבל אם נסתכל על השוויון
השני הזה כאן, נראה שהוא דורש ש-q0 כפול r1 שווה לאפס,
אבל הדרך היחידה שמכפלה
של שני מספרים ממשיים יכולה להיות שווה לאפס היא אם לפחות אחד מהמספרים
האלה עצמו שווה לאפס.
זה נקרא לפעמים
תכונת המכפלה האפסית של המספרים הממשיים.
דרך אחרת לומר את זה היא שמכפלה של שני מספרים ממשיים לא-אפסיים
היא תמיד לא-אפסית.
אז השוויון הזה ממש
כאן גורר ש-q0 שווה לאפס או ש-r1 שווה לאפס,
אבל מהשוויון הראשון והאחרון אנחנו רואים ששום אחת
משתי החלופות האלה לא יכולה להיות נכונה.
אם q0 שווה לאפס, אז המכפלה הזו חייבת להיות אפס, אבל היא לא שווה לאפס
ואם r1 שווה לאפס,
אז המכפלה הזו חייבת להיות שווה לאפס, אבל זה גם לא נכון.
אז יש לנו סתירה
ואנחנו מסיקים ש-X ו-Y אינם בלתי תלויים אז הם מתואמים.
מושג האי-תלות
שרק דנו בו וספציפית הניסוח שלו במונחי וקטורי
הסתברות קשור קשר הדוק
לפעולה שאפשר
לבצע על וקטורים שנקראת מכפלה טנזורית.
מכפלות טנזוריות אפשר
להגדיר לא רק עבור וקטורים אלא גם עבור מטריצות
ולמעשה את מושג המכפלה הטנזורית אפשר להגדיר
עבור הרבה סוגים אחרים של
אובייקטים מתמטיים גם כן.
אפשר לתאר אותן
בצורה די מופשטת שהיא גם חשובה וגם
שימושית במתמטיקה טהורה, אבל אפשר גם להגדיר
מכפלות טנזוריות עבור וקטורים
בצורה מאוד פשוטה וקונקרטית, וזו הדרך שניקח
בשיעור הזה.
אם יש לנו שני וקטורי עמודה Phi ו-Psi כתובים בצורות שרואים כאן כאשר סיגמא וגמא הן כל
בחירה של קבוצות מצבים קלאסיות
שנרצה או אינדקסים אם אתם מעדיפים, אז המכפלה הטנזורית של הוקטורים האלה היא הוקטור שרואים כאן.
אנחנו עוברים על כל האיברים
של המכפלה הקרטזית של שתי הקבוצות, סיגמא וגמא, והרשומה של הוקטור הזה
שמתאימה
לכל זוג ab, שנכתב
כמחרוזת כאן, שווה למכפלה של
הרשומות המתאימות
של שני הוקטורים האלה. במילים אחרות, הרשומה ab של Phi טנזור Psi היא מכפלת הרשומה a
של Phi והרשומה b של Psi,
וזו המשמעות של
מה שכתוב כאן.
בעצם, זו אותה פעולה שרק ראינו לפני כמה רגעים כשדנו באי-תלות
ועכשיו אנחנו פשוט נותנים לה שם.
הנה בדיוק אותה דוגמה
שראינו לפני רגע כתובה באופן יותר מפורש במונחי
המכפלה הטנזורית.
שוב, יש לנו ששישית שווה לרבע כפול שליש, אחד חלקי שתים עשרה שווה לרבע
כפול שליש וכן הלאה.
הנה, דרך אגב, כמה
דרכים חלופיות לכתוב את המכפלה הטנזורית
של שני וקטורים.
כשאנחנו משתמשים בסימון דיראק ואנחנו כותבים שני קטים זה ליד
זה ככה, הכוונה היא למכפלה טנזורית.
אז אפשר לחשוב על המכפלה הטנזורית כמין ברירת מחדל להכפלת שני וקטורי עמודה ביחד.
לא היה הגיוני
לחשוב על מכפלה של וקטורי עמודה ככה במונחי כפל מטריצות כי הממדים לא מסתדרים,
אז באמת אין חשש
לגבי דו-משמעות כאן.
אפשר גם לכתוב את
המכפלה הטנזורית ככה בתוך קט וזה אומר
בדיוק אותו דבר.
זו המכפלה הטנזורית
של שני הוקטורים.
הראשון מאוד נפוץ ולמעשה אולי יותר נפוץ לכתוב מכפלה טנזורית ככה בלי סמל המכפלה הטנזורית
מאשר לכלול את הסמל. השני
בהחלט הרבה פחות נפוץ, אבל הוא לפעמים די מועיל בעיקר
כדרך להימנע מהצורך
בסוגריים נוספים במצבים מסוימים.
אנחנו יכולים גם לבטא
מכפלות טנזוריות באופן מפורש במונחי עמודות
של מספרים ממש כמו שרואים כאן,
אם אנחנו לוקחים את המכפלה הטנזורית של שני וקטורי העמודה האלה כאן, אז זה הוקטור שאנחנו מקבלים
ואפשר לראות שהרשומות כאן הן מכפלות של הרשומות
שמגיעות משני הוקטורים האלה.
הסדר של הרשומות
של המכפלה הטנזורית עקבי עם
ההגדרה מלפני רגע בתנאי שאנחנו עוקבים אחרי המוסכמה
שתיארתי קודם לגבי סידור האיברים
של קבוצות מכפלה קרטזית.
עקיבה אחרי המוסכמה הזו שקולה לחשיבה
על האינדקסים של הוקטור הראשון כבעלי
חשיבות גבוהה יותר מהאינדקסים של הוקטור השני,
אז אפשר לראות שכאשר
אנחנו עוברים על הרשומות של המכפלה הטנזורית, יש לנו את כל המכפלות שמערבות את הרשומה הראשונה של
הוקטור הראשון בצד שמאל,
שזו אלפא אחד. אחר כך כל המכפלות
שמערבות את הרשומה השנייה של הוקטור בצד שמאל,
שזו אלפא שתיים וכן הלאה.
הנה דוגמה שבה
לוקטור בצד שמאל יש שלוש רשומות ולוקטור בצד
ימין יש ארבע רשומות כדי שנוכל לראות יותר
בבירור מה קורה.
יש לנו שלוש רשומות בוקטור הראשון, אז אנחנו מתחילים בלכתוב שלושה עותקים של הוקטור השני ואז אנחנו מכפילים כל אחד מהעותקים האלה
ברשומה המתאימה
בוקטור הראשון ככה.
אנחנו מכניסים את האלפות פנימה ככה, וכאן אנחנו פשוט
מכפילים וקטורים בסקלרים
ולבסוף אנחנו מסירים את
הסוגריים מהעותקים ואנחנו יוצרים וקטור עמודה
אחד כמו שרואים כאן.
כהערת אגב חשובה שימו לב שיש לנו את הנוסחאות הבאות למכפלה הטנזורית של
וקטורי בסיס סטנדרטי.
אם אנחנו לוקחים את המכפלה
הטנזורית של קט a וקט b, שאפשר לכתוב עם
סמל המכפלה הטנזורית או בלעדיו, כמו שרואים כאן,
אז התוצאה היא פשוט קט ab.
אם אנחנו רוצים לכתוב ab כזוג סדור במקום מחרוזת, אנחנו יכולים לעשות את זה ולקבל
את הביטוי הזה כאן,
אבל הרבה יותר נפוץ
לכתוב את זה ככה שבו אנחנו משמיטים את הסוגריים
אבל משאירים את הפסיק.
יש מובן שבו
הזה עם הסוגריים הוא אולי יותר מדויק, אבל זו מוסכמה די
סטנדרטית במתמטיקה
שסוגריים מוסרים כשהם לא הכרחיים או מועילים.
אפשר לחשוב עליהם כמשתמעים בזה כאן וזה פשוט פחות עמוס
ויותר נעים להסתכל עליו.
למכפלה הטנזורית יש
תכונה חשובה והיא שהיא בילינארית ומה שזה אומר הוא שהיא ליניארית
בכל אחד משני הארגומנטים בתנאי שהשני קבוע.
קצת יותר בפירוט היא
ליניארית בארגומנט הראשון שמבוטא על ידי שתי המשוואות האלה שרואים כאן,
הראשונה אומרת שאם
אנחנו מחברים שני וקטורים, Phi1 ו-Phi2 ואז לוקחים
את המכפלה הטנזורית עם Psi, אנחנו מקבלים את אותה תוצאה כאילו
לקחנו את המכפלה הטנזורית
עם Psi קודם ואז חיברנו.
השנייה אומרת שאם
אנחנו מכפילים וקטור Phi כלשהו בסקלר אלפא כלשהו ואז לוקחים
את המכפלה הטנזורית עם Psi,
התוצאה זהה לזו שנקבל אם קודם ניקח את המכפלה הטנזורית של Phi ו-Psi ואז נכפיל את התוצאה באלפא.
ויש לנו גם ליניאריות
בארגומנט השני שזה אותו דבר רק שהתפקידים של שני הארגומנטים מוחלפים.
התכונה הזו של בילינאריות
די ישירה לאימות מההגדרה, אבל טוב לכתוב את זה ככה כי נשתמש הרבה
בנוסחאות האלה.
שימו לב דרך אגב שסקלרים צפים בחופשיות דרך מכפלות טנזוריות במובן שמבוטא על ידי השוויונות
שרואים כאן.
כלומר אין הבדל
בין הכפלת הארגומנט הראשון בסקלר
אלפא במקרה הזה הכפלת הארגומנט
השני באותו סקלר
או הכפלת כל
הדבר באותו סקלר.
השוויונות האלה נובעים
משתי המשוואות האלה כאן ובגלל שאין
הבדל בין הוקטורים האלה, אנחנו יכולים פשוט לכתוב את
הביטוי כמו שרואים כאן
בלי סוגריים כי
אין צורך בהם.
הם לא מוסיפים בהירות
ולא מסירים דו-משמעות, אז אנחנו פשוט מסירים אותם ומקבלים
ביטוי נקי יותר.
כל זה מוכלל
לשלוש מערכות או יותר.
אפשר להגדיר את המכפלה הטנזורית
של שלושה וקטורים או יותר על ידי הכללת הנוסחה
למכפלה הטנזורית של שני וקטורים בצורה הטבעית,
שאפשר לראות מבוטאת כאן. כל רשומה של המכפלה הטנזורית ניתנת על ידי מכפלת
הרשומות המתאימות
של הוקטורים שאנחנו
לוקחים מהם מכפלה טנזורית.
דרך שקולה להגדיר
את המכפלה הטנזורית של שלושה וקטורים או יותר
היא לעשות את זה רקורסיבית ובסופו של דבר לחזור להגדרה
של המכפלה הטנזורית בין שני וקטורים. אז אם n הוא לפחות שלוש, אפשר לחשוב על
המכפלה הטנזורית של n וקטורים
Phi1 עד Phi n כמכפלה הטנזורית בין מה שנקבל אם ניקח
את המכפלה הטנזורית של n פחות אחד הראשונים
מביניהם עם הוקטור האחרון,
ואם אתם רוצים לדעת
מהי המכפלה הטנזורית של n פחות אחד הוקטורים הראשונים, אתם או מפעילים את הנוסחה
שוב במקרה ש-n פחות אחד
הוא לפחות שלוש או משתמשים בהגדרה
מקודם אם n פחות אחד שווה לשתיים.
שתי הדרכים לחשוב
על מכפלות טנזוריות של שלושה וקטורים או יותר הן שקולות.
הפעם כשיש לנו
שלושה וקטורים או יותר שאנחנו לוקחים מהם מכפלה טנזורית, אנחנו לא משתמשים במונח בילינארי,
אנחנו במקום זה משתמשים במונח מולטילינארי,
אבל הרעיון אותו דבר.
המכפלה הטנזורית ליניארית
בכל אחד מהמיקומים בתנאי שהוקטורים בכל
המיקומים האחרים
קבועים. נעבור למדידות
של מערכות מרובות במצבים הסתברותיים,
אנחנו מיד מקבלים מפרט לאיך שמדידות
עובדות למערכות מרובות על ידי פשוט לחשוב עליהן
באופן קולקטיבי כמערכות בודדות
בתנאי שכל
המערכות נמדדות.
כדוגמה פשוטה, נניח שיש לנו שני
ביטים X ו-Y וביחד הם במצב ההסתברותי
הזה כאן,
שראינו קודם. באופן טבעי, אם אנחנו מודדים
את שני הביטים האלה, נקבל את התוצאה 00
כלומר אפס למדידה הראשונה ואפס למדידה השנייה עם הסתברות של חצי ונקבל את התוצאה 1,1
עם הסתברות של חצי גם כן. זה די ישיר.
בעצם, מדידה של כל המערכות שקולה למדידה
של המערכת המורכבת כולה.
אם אנחנו לא מודדים את כל
המערכות לעומת זאת, אלא במקום זה אנחנו מודדים
רק חלק מהמערכות, אז המצב לא
כל כך ברור מיד
נגביל את תשומת הלב שלנו שוב למקרה של רק שתי
מערכות כדי לראות את המהות של מה שקורה בהגדרה
הכי פשוטה שאפשר.
אנחנו יכולים לשאול את השאלה הבאה, נניח שיש לנו שתי מערכות, X ו-Y שביחד כזוג
במצב הסתברותי מסוים כלשהו.
מה קורה אם אנחנו מודדים
רק את X ולא עושים כלום ל-Y?
ובכן, אפשר לענות על השאלה הזו באמצעות תורת הסתברות בסיסית.
ראשית, אנחנו יודעים שההסתברות שהמדידה
נותנת תוצאה מסוימת חייבת להינתן על ידי הנוסחה
שרואים כאן.
אפשר לחשוב על ההסתברויות לכל אחד מהמצבים הקלאסיים
של הזוג XY כאילו מדדנו את שניהם ולסכום על כל ההסתברויות
שעקביות עם X להיות באיזה מצב קלאסי
a שמעניין אותנו.
לכן הסכום כאן הוא רק על המצבים הקלאסיים b של Y.
דרך אחת לחשוב על הנוסחה
הזו היא שההסתברות לראות מצב קלאסי מסוים
של X אם אנחנו מודדים אותו
חייבת להיות עקבית עם ההסתברות לראות את המצב הזה אם
היינו מודדים גם את Y, למרות שלא מדדנו,
זה מאוד טבעי ואינטואיטיבי. ההסתברות שמדידה של X תיתן תוצאה מסוימת לא יכולה להיות תלויה בשאלה האם Y
גם נמדד
ללא קשר לתוצאה.
אז זה אומר לנו מה
ההסתברויות לתוצאות האפשריות
השונות של המדידה, אבל מה קורה ל-Y או לידע
שלנו על Y כתוצאה?
התשובה היא שעדיין
יכולה להיות אי ודאות לגבי מצבו של Y כתוצאה
ממדידת X
וראיית תוצאה מסוימת. ואי הודאות הזו מיוצגת על ידי הנוסחה הזו כאן להסתברות המותנית
ש-Y נמצא במצב קלאסי
מסוים b, בהינתן ש-X נמצא במצב קלאסי כלשהו,
איזה מצב קלאסי a שהוא,
שבמקרה מדדנו.
ליתר דיוק, ההסתברות ש-Y
נמצא במצב קלאסי b כלשהו, בהינתן ש-X נמצא במצב הקלאסי a,
שווה להסתברות
ש-X נמצא ב-a ו-Y נמצא ב-b חלקי ההסתברות ש-X
נמצא במצב הקלאסי a.
אז אם אנחנו מודדים את X, אנחנו הולכים לראות
מצבים קלאסיים שונים עם הסתברויות שנקבעות
על ידי הנוסחה הזו כאן
ובהתאם לתוצאה שנקבל, עדיין יכולה להיות לנו אי ודאות לגבי המצב הקלאסי של Y ואי
הודאות הזו משתקפת
על ידי הנוסחה הזו כאן.
יש בעצם דרך מאוד קלה
לנסח מחדש את כל זה ולבצע חישובים
למקרים ספציפיים באמצעות סימון דיראק
וזה הולך ככה.
אנחנו מתחילים בלכתוב את
המצב ההסתברותי של XY כוקטור ככה, וזה
לגמרי כללי.
הרשומות מסומנות כ-Pab ואלה יכולים להיות כל מספרים כל עוד הוקטור כולו
הוא וקטור הסתברות.
אפשר לבטא את קט ab כמכפלה
טנזורית כמו שרואים כאן ואז אפשר להשתמש
בבילינאריות של המכפלה הטנזורית
וספציפית בעובדה שהיא ליניארית בארגומנט השני כדי לבטא את הוקטור הזה
כמו שרואים כאן.
מה שאנחנו עושים זה למעשה לבודד את וקטורי הבסיס הסטנדרטי
בצד שמאל ולשים מה שצריך
בצד ימין
כדי לאפשר את זה כי זה הולך לחשוף מה קורה כשאנחנו
מודדים את המערכת הראשונה X.
ספציפית ההסתברות
לקבל תוצאה מסוימת a היא הסכום על כל ההסתברויות שמופיעות בסוגריים
ליד קט a.
ובהתניה על קבלת
תוצאה מסוימת a, וקטור ההסתברות שמתאר את אי הודאות שנותרה לגבי Y
הוא הוקטור שהיה
בסוגריים ליד a.
חוץ מזה שאנחנו צריכים לנרמל אותו כדי שיהיה וקטור הסתברות וזה אומר שאנחנו
צריכים לחלק את הוקטור הזה
בסכום הרשומות באותו וקטור כדי ליצור וקטור הסתברות.
כאן דרך אגב, הסכום הוא על כל
c בגמא במקום b רק כדי להשתמש בשם משתנה שונה כדי שלא יהיה בלבול
לגבי התחום של
המשתנים אם תרצו.
הסכומים במונה
ובמכנה צריכים להיחשב כדברים נפרדים ואפשר למנוע כל סיכוי
לבלבול לגבי זה
על ידי שימוש במשתנים
שונים לשני הסכומים.
הנה דוגמה מהירה כדי
להמחיש איך כל זה עובד.
נניח ש-XY הוא זוג ביטים במצב ההסתברותי הזה כאן כדי להבין מה קורה
כשאנחנו מודדים את הביט הראשון
ולא עושים כלום לשני, אנחנו כותבים את הוקטור כמו שרואים כאן כאשר קט אפס וקט
אחד במיקום הראשון
מבודדים בדיוק כמו
שתיארנו לפני כמה רגעים.
האפשרות הראשונה היא
שתוצאת המדידה היא אפס וההסתברות
שזה יקרה היא הסכום של ההסתברויות
בתוך הסוגריים
שנמצאות בטנזור לקט אפס. אז אנחנו מקבלים אחד חלקי שתים עשרה ועוד רבע, שזה שליש ובהתניה
על התוצאה אפס.
המצב ההסתברותי של Y
הופך לוקטור הזה מנורמל או שקול לכך מחולק בהסתברות
שרק חישבנו, ואז מה שנקבל הוא
הוקטור הזה כאן.
האפשרות השנייה היא שתוצאת המדידה היא אחד והחישוב
נעשה בצורה דומה באמצעות האיבר השני בביטוי
במקום האיבר הראשון. ואם תרצו לוודא את הפרטים, קדימה כמו תמיד והשהו את הסרטון כדי לתת לעצמכם רגע לעשות את זה.
אפשר לבצע את אותם סוגים
של חישובים כדי להבין מה קורה כש-Y
נמדד במקום X.
זו אותה שיטה עד כדי סימטריה בין שתי המערכות.
הפעם אנחנו כותבים את
וקטור ההסתברות ככה, מבודדים את וקטורי הבסיס הסטנדרטי בצד ימין כמו שרואים כאן,
אבל מלבד זאת זה עובד
בדיוק באותו אופן.
אפשר גם להשתמש בשיטה הזו
ליותר משתי מערכות.
זה יכול להיות קצת
מבולגן לכתוב את כל הביטויים הנדרשים, אבל מבחינה מושגית זה
בדיוק אותו רעיון.
לסיום, עבור החלק של השיעור
על מידע קלאסי, נסתכל על פעולות
על מצבים הסתברותיים
של מערכות מרובות. בעקבות אותו היגיון שכבר ראינו כמה פעמים.
אנחנו מסיקים שפעולות הסתברותיות על מערכות מרובות הן בדיוק
כמו פעולות הסתברותיות על מערכות בודדות שמיוצגות
על ידי מטריצות סטוכסטיות.
אבל הפעם למטריצות האלה
יש שורות ועמודות שמתאימות למכפלה הקרטזית של קבוצות המצבים הקלאסיות
של המערכות הבודדות.
כלומר אנחנו פשוט
רואים מערכת מורכבת כאילו היא מערכת אחת וחוזרים לתיאור של איך פעולות הסתברותיות עובדות
למערכות בודדות מהשיעור
הקודם.
הנה דוגמה של פעולה שנקראת פעולת
NOT מבוקרת על שני ביטים X ו-Y.
זו למעשה פעולה דטרמיניסטית והאופן שבו היא עובדת הוא
שאם X שווה לאחד, אז פעולת NOT מתבצעת על Y
ואחרת אם X שווה
לאפס אז כלום לא קורה.
הביט X נקרא לפעמים
ביט בקרה כי הוא קובע האם
פעולת ה-NOT מופעלת על Y או לא
ו-Y נקרא ביט המטרה כי הוא הביט שנפעל עליו על ידי פעולת ה-NOT.
אפשר גם לדמיין
החלפת התפקידים של X ו-Y כך ש-Y הופך לביט
הבקרה ו-X הופך למטרה, אבל זו פעולה שונה
מזו שמתוארת כאן כי הפעולה אינה
סימטרית בין X ו-Y.
שתיהן נקראות
פעולות NOT מבוקרות, ואנחנו רק צריכים לציין
איזה מהביטים הוא ביט הבקרה ואיזה
הוא ביט המטרה.
לפעולה הזו יש את הפעולה
שרואים כאן על מצבי בסיס סטנדרטי ואפשר לבדוק את
הפעולה מול ההגדרה
של הפעולה. והנה הייצוג המטריצי
של הפעולה.
כשאנחנו חושבים על הפעולה הזו, יש לנו בראש שיש
שני ביטים נפרדים האלה והם ממלאים את התפקידים שרק תיארתי כש-X
הוא ביט הבקרה
ו-Y הוא ביט המטרה, אבל אין באמת כלום
בפעולה הזו כאן או בייצוג המטריצי הזה
שדורש שנחשוב
על שני הביטים האלה כביטים נפרדים.
אפשר לחלופין פשוט
לחשוב על הפעולה הזו כפעולה דטרמיניסטית
על מערכת עם ארבעה מצבים קלאסיים
שהחלטנו לקרוא להם
0,0, 0,1, 1,0 ו-1,1.
הנה דוגמה נוספת של
פעולה הסתברותית על שני ביטים, שאינה פעולה
דטרמיניסטית הפעם.
הפעולה מגדירה את Y להיות שווה ל-X עם הסתברות של חצי ואחרת זה הולך בכיוון ההפוך ומגדיר את X להיות שווה ל-Y.
לפעולה הזו אין שם מיוחד היא רק נועדה כדוגמה.
והנה הייצוג המטריצי
של הפעולה הזו.
אפשר לראות שאפשר לבטא אותה כממוצע של שתי מטריצות, אחת שמייצגת את
הפעולה הדטרמיניסטית
שבה Y מוגדר לאיזה
ערך שמאוחסן ב-X והשנייה שמגדירה
את X להיות שווה ל-Y.
אז כאן אנחנו רואים שאפשר לקחת ממוצעים של מטריצות סטוכסטיות כדי לקבל חדשות בדיוק כמו שהיה לנו בשיעור הקודם.
עכשיו, בואו נשקול
את השאלה הבאה. נניח שיש לנו שתי
פעולות הסתברותיות כל אחת על המערכת שלה
מתוארות כרגיל על ידי מטריצות סטוכסטיות
וליתר דיוק, נניח ש-M היא
פעולה הסתברותית
על מערכת X ו-N היא
פעולה הסתברותית על מערכת Y.
השאלה היא אם אנחנו
מבצעים בו-זמנית את M על X ואת N על Y, איך אנחנו מתארים
את ההשפעה שיש לזה
על המערכת המורכבת XY?
אם חושבים על זה
באופן אינטואיטיבי לרגע, אם אנחנו מבצעים בו-זמנית
את שתי הפעולות על המערכות שלהן בהתאמה,
אז אנחנו למעשה
מבצעים פעולה על המערכת המורכבת, אז צריך לתאר אותה
על ידי מטריצה סטוכסטית כלשהי.
התשובה הקצרה לשאלה
הזו היא שהמטריצה מתקבלת על ידי לקיחת מכפלה טנזורית, לא בין וקטורים כמו
שדיברנו קודם,
אלא בין מטריצות במקרה
הזה, המטריצות M ו-N.
אז בואו ניקח כמה רגעים
כדי לדון במכפלות טנזוריות של מטריצות ואז נחזור
לשאלה הזו.
הנה ההגדרה
של המכפלה הטנזורית בין מטריצות והיא
מאוד אנלוגית למכפלה הטנזורית בין וקטורים.
אם אנחנו מניחים ששתי
המטריצות שאנחנו עובדים איתן כתובות בצורות שרואים כאן כך שהרשומות של M
מסומנות אלפא ab כאשר a ו-b
עוברים על קבוצת מצבים קלאסית כלשהי סיגמא והרשומות של N
מסומנות בטא cd כאשר c ו-d
עוברים על קבוצת מצבים קלאסית כלשהי גמא.
אז המכפלה של M ו-N היא המטריצה שרואים כאן.
מה שיש לנו דומה
למכפלה הטנזורית בין וקטורים.
השורות והעמודות של M טנזור N מתאימות לזוגות של מצבים קלאסיים שנכתבים כמחרוזות כאן,
והרשומות הן מכפלות של הרשומות המתאימות של M ו-N.
הנה דרך אחרת לכתוב את זה במונחי הרשומות הבודדות
של המטריצות האלה.
הרשומה ac bd של M טנזור N היא המכפלה של הרשומה ab
של M והרשומה cd של N.
יש דרך נוספת לתאר
M טנזור N, והיא שזו המטריצה
היחידה שמעבירה כל וקטור מהצורה Phi טנזור Psi
למכפלה הטנזורית של M מופעלת על Phi עם N מופעלת על Psi, וזה חייב להיות נכון לכל בחירה
של הוקטורים האלה Phi ו-Psi.
דרך אחת לחשוב על
זה היא שהמכפלה הטנזורית של מטריצות מסתדרת מצוין עם המכפלה הטנזורית בין וקטורים.
זו משוואה שהיינו
מקווים באופן טבעי שתהיה נכונה ואכן היא כן.
במונחי מטריצות שכתובות
באופן מפורש, אפשר להגדיר את המכפלה
הטנזורית כמו שרואים כאן.
יש הרבה נקודות במשוואה הזו והן נועדו
להמחיש את הדפוס, שהוא אותו דפוס
שהיה לנו עבור וקטורים רק שעכשיו יש לנו שורות ועמודות
בניגוד לסתם וקטורי עמודה.
למקרה שזה לא ברור, הדוגמה
הבאה עשויה לעזור.
כאן אנחנו מדברים על
המכפלה הטנזורית של שתי מטריצות שתיים על שתיים.
קודם כותבים ארבעה
עותקים של המטריצה השנייה, אחד לכל רשומה של המטריצה הראשונה.
מכפילים כל אחד מהעותקים
של המטריצה השנייה ברשומה
המתאימה של המטריצה הראשונה,
ואז אוספים את הכל למטריצת
ארבע על ארבע אחת כמו שרואים כאן.
אפשר גם להגדיר את
המכפלה הטנזורית של שלוש מטריצות או יותר באופן אנלוגי ואולי הדרך הכי קלה
לבטא את זה
היא כמו שרואים כאן
שבו יש לנו נוסחה לכל רשומה של המכפלה הטנזורית, שהיא פשוט מכפלת
הרשומות המתאימות.
אפשר גם להגדיר את המכפלה הטנזורית של שלוש מטריצות או יותר רקורסיבית במונחי המכפלה
הטנזורית של רק שתי מטריצות בדיוק כמו שהיה לנו עבור וקטורים.
והערה אחרונה היא
שהמכפלה הטנזורית של מטריצות היא כפלית, מה שאומר שמכפלה
של מכפלות טנזוריות
שווה למכפלה הטנזורית
של המכפלות.
אפשר לחשוב על
זה כהכללה של הנוסחה מלפני כמה רגעים לפעולה של מכפלה טנזורית
של מטריצות
על מכפלה טנזורית של וקטורים. ושוב, זה משהו שבוודאי
היינו מקווים שיהיה נכון ואפשר לשמוח שזה אכן כך
ונשתמש בעובדה הזו
בכל פעם שנצטרך.
ועכשיו אפשר לחזור
לשאלה מקודם ששואלת איך אנחנו מתארים
את ההשפעה של ביצוע פעולה M על מערכת X
ופעולה N על מערכת Y ביחד כפעולה
על המערכת המורכבת XY.
והתשובה לשאלה
הזו היא שהפעולה מתוארת על ידי
המכפלה הטנזורית של M ו-N.
מכפלות טנזוריות מייצגות אי-תלות הפעם בין פעולות בניגוד למה שראינו
קודם עבור וקטורי הסתברות.
הנה דוגמה מהירה. נניח שאנחנו מבצעים
את הפעולה ההסתברותית שמתוארת על ידי המטריצה הזו על ביט X.
במקרה זו פעולה
שראינו בשיעור הראשון ובו-זמנית אנחנו מבצעים
פעולת NOT על ביט Y.
הפעולה המשולבת על הזוג XY מיוצגת אפוא על ידי המכפלה הטנזורית של המטריצות שמתאימות לשתי הפעולות האלה.
הנה זו של X והנה
פעולת ה-NOT של Y ואנחנו מקבלים את המטריצה
שרואים כאן.
ואפשר לראות שאכן
זו מטריצה סטוכסטית וזה תמיד יהיה המצב.
המכפלה הטנזורית של כל
שתי מטריצות סטוכסטיות או כל מספר של מטריצות
סטוכסטיות לצורך העניין תמיד תהיה סטוכסטית.
זה מצב מאוד נפוץ
שאנחנו נתקלים במצב שבו פעולה אחת מתבצעת
על מערכת אחת ולא עושים כלום למערכת אחרת.
במצב הזה, אנחנו עוקבים בדיוק אחרי אותה מתכונת עם ההבנה שעשיית כלום מיוצגת על ידי מטריצת היחידה.
לדוגמה, אם יש לנו שני ביטים X ו-Y
ואנחנו מאפסים את הביט X למצב אפס, שזה אותו דבר
כמו ביצוע הפונקציה
הקבועה אפס על X ואנחנו לא עושים כלום ל-Y, אז הפעולה המתקבלת על הזוג XY
מיוצגת על ידי המכפלה
הטנזורית הזו כאן.
כל זה מוכלל
לכל מספר של מערכות ונראה עוד כמה דוגמאות כשנעבור להקשר הקוונטי, שעובד בדיוק באותו אופן
חוץ מזה שיש לנו מטריצות אוניטריות במקום מטריצות סטוכסטיות, ודי על
מידע קלאסי לעת עתה.
עכשיו נפנה את תשומת הלב
שלנו למידע קוונטי ואיך הוא עובד למערכות מרובות.
הדפוס זהה לזה שהיה
עבור מידע קלאסי.
אנחנו יכולים לראות מערכות קוונטיות מרובות כמערכות מורכבות בודדות ולהחיל את מה שאנחנו יודעים
מהשיעור הקודם.
שוב, מכפלות טנזוריות
ימלאו תפקיד מפתח ובסך הכל נקבל תיאור לאיך שמידע קוונטי
עובד למערכות מרובות.
שהוא מאוד אנלוגי
ודומה מתמטית למה שרק ראינו עבור
מידע קלאסי.
נתחיל עם מצבים קוונטיים.
מצבים קוונטיים של מערכות מרובות מיוצגים על ידי וקטורי עמודה עם רשומות של מספרים מרוכבים
ונורמה אוקלידית השווה לאחד
בדיוק כמו מצבים קוונטיים
של מערכות בודדות.
הפעם האינדקסים של
וקטורי המצב הקוונטי מתאימים למכפלה הקרטזית של קבוצות המצבים הקלאסיות
של המערכות הבודדות
כי שוב, זו
קבוצת המצבים הקלאסית של המערכת המורכבת.
לדוגמה, אם X ו-Y הם qubit-ים, אז קבוצת המצבים
הקלאסית לזוג XY ביחד היא המכפלה הקרטזית של
האלפבית הבינארי עם עצמו,
שאפשר לחשוב עליה כקבוצת
כל המחרוזות הבינאריות באורך שתיים.
אז הוקטורים האלה שרואים כאן הם כולם דוגמאות של וקטורי
מצב קוונטי של XY.
אם אנחנו רוצים, אנחנו יכולים לחלופין לכתוב
את הוקטורים האלה ככה שבו יש לנו קט נפרד
לכל qubit
כאשר המכפלה הטנזורית
ביניהם משתמעת.
או שאפשר גם לכתוב את
סמל המכפלה הטנזורית באופן מפורש ככה אם אתם מעדיפים.
ואפשרות נוספת היא
לתת לקטים אינדקס תחתון עם שמות המערכות
שהם מייצגים ככה.
ואפשר לעשות את זה עם
סמל המכפלה הטנזורית או בלעדיו.
זה יכול לפעמים להיות מאוד מועיל לשמור על סדר בדברים.
אלה סתם סגנונות שונים לביטוי אותם וקטורים ואנחנו יכולים לבחור מה שנרצה או מה שנעדיף או
מה שהכי הגיוני
למצב הנוכחי. כשדברים נהיים
יותר מסובכים למשל, אנחנו עשויים להחליט שאחד מהסגנונות
האלה מוסיף בהירות
ואנחנו חופשיים לעשות
כל בחירה שנרצה.
מכפלות טנזוריות של וקטורי מצב קוונטי הן גם וקטורי מצב קוונטי.
במקרה של שתי מערכות למשל, אם Phi הוא וקטור מצב קוונטי
של מערכת X ו-Psi הוא וקטור מצב קוונטי
של מערכת Y,
אז המכפלה הטנזורית של Phi ו-Psi היא וקטור מצב קוונטי של XY.
אנחנו קוראים למצבים ככה מצבי מכפלה ובדומה למה שראינו בהקשר ההסתברותי הקלאסי, הם מייצגים אי-תלות
בין המערכות X ו-Y.
אז למשל, אם לאדם אחד יש מעבדה
בחלק אחד של העולם והוא יוצר מערכת X ומאתחל אותה למצב הקוונטי Phi
ואדם אחר בחלק
אחר של העולם מאתחל באופן עצמאי מערכת Y למצב הקוונטי Psi,
אז אם אנחנו בוחרים לחשוב על XY כמערכת אחת למרות ששני חלקיה בחלקים שונים של העולם,
אז המערכת המורכבת XY נמצאת
במצב Phi טנזור Psi.
כל זה מוכלל
ליותר משתי מערכות בצורה הטבעית.
אם יש לנו מצבים
קוונטיים Psi1 עד PsiN של מערכות נפרדות X1 עד Xn, אז המכפלה הטנזורית של n הוקטורים האלה
מייצגת מצב קוונטי, שנקרא שוב מצב מכפלה של המערכת המורכבת X1 עד Xn.
הנה דוגמה של מצב
קוונטי של שני qubit-ים.
למרות שאולי זה לא
נראה ככה מיד. זו דוגמה של מצב מכפלה כי אפשר לכתוב
אותו כמכפלה טנזורית כמו שרואים כאן.
אז זו דוגמה של
מצב מכפלה ללא קשר לאיך שהוא כתוב, מה שרלוונטי הוא האם
אפשר או לא אפשר לכתוב אותו כמכפלה טנזורית.
המצב הקוונטי הזה, לעומת זאת, שהוא שוב מצב של שני
qubit-ים אינו מצב מכפלה.
הוא דומה ברוחו
לדוגמה שראינו בהקשר ההסתברותי של שני ביטים אקראיים מתואמים לחלוטין
ואותו טיעון חושף שלא ניתן לכתוב
אותו כמכפלה טנזורית.
אז בואו נזיז את זה לפה ונסתכל על הטיעון קצת יותר לעומק.
בואו נדמיין שאפשר
לכתוב את המצב הזה כמכפלה טנזורית של
שני וקטורים Phi ו-Psi.
הרשומה שמתאימה
למצב הקלאסי 0,1 היא אפס עבור הוקטור הזה, שאפשר לראות פשוט בהסתכלות עליו.
אבל זה היה גורר, אם הוקטור היה מכפלה
טנזורית של שני וקטורים שהרשומה אפס של Phi
כפול הרשומה אחד של Psi
היו שווים לאפס, אבל זה אומר שגם
הרשומה אפס של Phi או הרשומה אחד של Psi שווה לאפס
או ששניהם יכולים להיות שווים לאפס, אבל זה סותר את העובדה
ששתי המכפלות האלה כאן חייבות שתיהן להיות לא-אפסיות.
הן שוות לאחד
חלקי שורש שתיים. הטיעון למעשה כמעט
זהה למה שהיה לנו בהקשר ההסתברותי.
אין כאן שום דבר קוונטי
ייחודי בכלל.
בכל מקרה, מה שאנחנו מגלים הוא שהמצב המקורי אינו מצב מכפלה.
שימו לב שלא חשוב
ששני המספרים האלה כאן הם אחד חלקי שורש שתיים.
כל מה שמשנה הוא ששני
הערכים אינם אפס.
המצב הקוונטי הספציפי הזה
הוא מאוד מעניין. זו דוגמה של מצב
שזור של שני qubit-ים.
נדבר עוד על
שזירה בהמשך הסדרה.
שזירה יכולה להיות מסובכת, במיוחד כשאנחנו
מדברים על מצבים קוונטיים בניסוח הכללי
של מידע קוונטי,
אבל כאן בתיאור המפושט של מידע קוונטי שזירה שקולה לחוסר אי-תלות.
אז עבור וקטור מצב קוונטי,
אם הוא לא מצב מכפלה, הוא מצב שזור
והמצב הספציפי הזה
נחשב בדרך כלל
לדוגמה הארכיטיפית של מצב קוונטי שזור.
ולמעשה, אנחנו לפעמים
חושבים על המצב הזה כמייצג יחידה אחת של שזירה, במיוחד כשאנחנו
חושבים על שזירה
כמשאב שאפשר להשתמש בו
כדי לעשות דברים מעניינים.
המצב הקוונטי שרק
דיברנו עליו הוא אחד מארבעת מצבי Bell, שאפשר לראות כאן
יחד עם השמות
שנפוצים למצבים האלה, Phi פלוס, Phi מינוס,
Psi פלוס ו-Psi מינוס.
כולם שזורים
והם אכן יוצרים בסיס למרחב של כל
הוקטורים שמייצגים מצבים של שני qubit-ים.
אז ארבעת הוקטורים האלה ביחד
נקראים בסיס Bell.
זו אוסף מאוד נפוץ
של מצבים קוונטיים שנקרא
על שם John Bell, שהיה פיזיקאי שתרם תרומות
חשובות מאוד
לחקר השזירה בשנות ה-60.
הנה כמה דוגמאות ידועות של מצבים קוונטיים של שלושה qubit-ים.
הראשון נקרא מצב GHZ.
הוא קצת כמו מצב Phi
פלוס שרק ראינו חוץ מזה שזה לשלושה qubit-ים במקום שניים.
והדוגמה השנייה נקראת מצב W והיא נראית כמו שרואים כאן, אז היא אחידה על
שלוש המחרוזות הבינאריות
באורך שלוש שיש להן
בדיוק ביט אחד שמוגדר לאחד.
אף אחד מהמצבים האלה אינו מצב מכפלה ולשניהם יש תכונות מעניינות והם עולים די נפוץ כדוגמאות, אז טוב לדעת עליהם
ונראה אותם שוב.
הבא נדבר על
מדידות של מערכות במצבים קוונטיים.
בעקבות אותו היגיון
שעקבנו אחריו עד כה בשיעור, שהוא לחשוב על מערכות מרובות
כאילו הן מערכות בודדות. אנחנו מגיעים מיד לתיאור של איך מדידות של
מערכות קוונטיות מרובות עובדות
בתנאי שכל
המערכות נמדדות.
כלומר אם יש לנו
וקטור מצב קוונטי כלשהו Psi שמייצג מצב
קוונטי של n-יית מערכות
X1 עד Xn ואנחנו מודדים
את המערכת המורכבת כולה, שזה שקול למדידה
של כל אחת מהמערכות הבודדות, אז כל n-יית אפשרית
של מצבים קלאסיים תהיה תוצאת המדידה
עם הסתברות השווה
לערך המוחלט בריבוע של הרשומה של Psi שמתאימה
לאותה n-יית.
לדוגמה, אם יש לנו
זוג מערכות XY במצב הקוונטי הזה כאן, אז אם אנחנו מודדים את שתי המערכות,
אז נקבל את התוצאה אפס לבבות כלומר אפס למדידה של X ולבבות למדידה של Y
עם הסתברות של תשע חלקי עשרים וחמש ונקבל את התוצאה אחד
עלים עם הסתברות של 16/25.
זה באמת די ישיר. אנחנו בעצם מתעלמים מהעובדה שאלה שתי מערכות נפרדות ורואים אותן כאילו
הן מערכת אחת,
אבל זה מעלה את
השאלה הטבעית הבאה, שכבר שקלנו
בהקשר הקלאסי.
נניח שיש לנו שתי מערכות X ו-Y שביחד
במצב קוונטי כלשהו ואנחנו לא מודדים את שתיהן, אלא
מודדים רק מערכת אחת.
נניח שאנחנו מודדים את מערכת X ולא עושים כלום ל-Y.
כמובן, אפשר גם לשאול מה קורה אם מודדים את Y ולא את
X ובאופן כללי יותר מה קורה אם יש לנו
שלוש מערכות או יותר
ומודדים תת-קבוצה ממשית שלהן. אבל ברגע שיש לנו
תשובה לשאלה הזו, יהיו לנו תשובות גם
לשאלות האלה.
אנחנו יודעים שבאופן כללי
וקטור מצב קוונטי של הזוג XY לוקח את
הצורה שרואים כאן, בהנחה כרגיל שסיגמא וגמא
הן קבוצות המצבים הקלאסיות
של X ו-Y בהתאמה.
הרשומות של הוקטור הזה
מסומנות אלפא ab שעוברות על כל הבחירות האפשריות של a ו-b,
והן יכולות להיות כל מספר מרוכב שגורם לוקטור הזה
להיות וקטור יחידה.
עכשיו אנחנו כבר יודעים שאם
שתי המערכות נמדדות, אז אנחנו מקבלים את ההסתברויות לתוצאות האפשריות השונות
על ידי לקיחת הערך המוחלט בריבוע של הרשומה המתאימה.
ואז אם רק X נמדד, אז ההסתברות
לקבל תוצאה מסוימת a ניתנת על ידי הביטוי הזה,
אנחנו פשוט סוכמים על כל
התוצאות האפשריות b, שהיו מתקבלות
אם Y גם היה נמדד למרות שלא נמדד.
הרעיון זהה לזה שבהקשר
ההסתברותי.
ההסתברות לקבל
תוצאה מסוימת כש-X נמדד לא יכולה
להיות תלויה בשאלה האם Y גם נמדד או לא.
אז זה אומר לנו מה
ההסתברויות לתוצאות האפשריות השונות.
בנוסף, יהיה שינוי כלשהו
במצב של Y כתוצאה מביצוע
המדידה הזו על X וקבלת תוצאה מסוימת.
אז בואו נסתכל על איך זה עובד.
בדומה למה שעשינו
בהקשר ההסתברותי, אנחנו יכולים לבטא את
וקטור המצב הקוונטי Psi כמו שרואים כאן
כאשר Phi a הוא הוקטור הזה לכל בחירה של מצב קלאסי a של המערכת X,
אנחנו משתמשים בבילינאריות
של המכפלה הטנזורית בדיוק כמו קודם.
רק שעכשיו בחרנו לקרוא
לוקטורים השונים האלה Phi a, רק לנוחות.
כבר שמנו לב שההסתברות שהמדידה תיתן
כל תוצאה אפשרית a היא כמו שרואים כאן,
אבל עכשיו אפשר לראות שההסתברות הזו שווה לנורמה האוקלידית בריבוע
של הוקטור Phi a,
ועכשיו כתוצאה מהמדידה של X שנותנת תוצאה מסוימת a, יש לנו שהמצב הקוונטי
של המערכת המורכבת XY
הופך למצב שרואים
כאן.
בדיוק כמו שהיה לנו למערכות בודדות, המצב קורס בעצם, אבל הוא לא קורס
לגמרי באופן כללי,
הוא קורס רק עד כמה שצריך כדי להיות עקבי
עם המדידה של X שנותנת את התוצאה a.
המצב הקוונטי של Y הופך ל-Phi a מנורמל כלומר שאנחנו
מחלקים בנורמה האוקלידית שלו
כדי שיהפוך לוקטור יחידה. זה אנלוגי למה שקרה בהקשר
ההסתברותי שבו במקום לחלק
בנורמה האוקלידית,
חילקנו בסכום
הרשומות של Phi a כדי לקבל וקטור הסתברות.
אבל כאן כי אנחנו
מדברים על מצבים קוונטיים, אנחנו מחלקים בנורמה האוקלידית
כדי לקבל וקטור מצב קוונטי.
בואו נסתכל על כמה דוגמאות כדי לראות איך זה עובד
למצב ספציפי.
הנה המצב שנשקול. אנחנו מניחים ש-X ו-Y הם qubit-ים והם במצב המסוים הזה Psi.
ונניח ש-X נמדד.
אנחנו מתחילים בלכתוב את המצב
Psi כמו שרואים כאן, ולמעשה מבודדים את
גורמי הבסיס הסטנדרטי של X
ומכפילים אותם טנזורית במה שצריך כדי לקבל את המצב המקורי.
בדיוק כמו בתיאור הכללי
מלפני רגע.
ההסתברות לקבל את התוצאה אפס היא הנורמה האוקלידית בריבוע
של הוקטור הזה כאן.
הדבר שאנחנו מכפילים טנזורית לקט אפס בביטוי שלנו של הוקטור Psi.
ואז ההסתברות היא שלושה רבעים ובהתניה
על קבלת התוצאה אפס.
המצב הקוונטי של
הזוג XY הופך לזה שבו אנחנו מנרמלים את
הוקטור שבטנזור לקט אפס,
וזה שקול לחלוקה
בשורש הריבועי של ההסתברות שרק
חישבנו.
אפשר אז לפשט
וזה מה שנקבל.
ההסתברות לקבל את
תוצאת המדידה אחד מחושבת באופן דומה.
אנחנו לוקחים את הנורמה האוקלידית בריבוע
של הוקטור הזה כאן. הדבר שבטנזור לקט
אחד בביטוי שלנו של Psi
וההסתברות
המתקבלת היא רבע, מה שחייב להיות כמובן, כי ההסתברויות
שלנו חייבות להסתכם לאחד.
במקרה הזה, המצב הקוונטי של XY הופך לזה שבו שוב אנחנו מנרמלים על ידי חלוקה בנורמה האוקלידית
כך שנקבל את וקטור המצב הקוונטי
הזה כתוצאה.
אותה שיטה משמשת
באופן סימטרי, אם Y נמדד במקום X.
הנה וקטור המצב הקוונטי המקורי, והפעם כי Y
נמדד במקום X,
אנחנו מבטאים את הוקטור Psi
כמו שרואים כאן, שבו הפעם אנחנו מבודדים את
וקטורי הבסיס הסטנדרטי של Y
במקום X ומכפילים
טנזורית במה שצריך כדי לקבל ביטוי של Psi.
אם עוברים על החישוב, שאפשר לבדוק על ידי
השהיית הסרטון אם תרצו.
אנחנו רואים שההסתברות
לקבל את התוצאה אפס היא חמש שמיניות הפעם, והנה
וקטור המצב הקוונטי
שמתקבל בהתניה
על קבלת התוצאה הזו.
וההסתברות לקבל את
התוצאה אחד היא שלוש שמיניות, ובמקרה הזה זהו
וקטור המצב הקוונטי שלנו.
אפשר להשתמש בדיוק באותה שיטה במקרה שיש לכם יותר משתי מערכות ותת-קבוצה ממשית כלשהי
מהן נמדדת.
ויש דוגמה
בתוכן ספר הלימוד לשיעור הזה שאפשר
לבדוק אם מעניין אתכם.
בקיצור, אנחנו תמיד יכולים לחלק את המערכות לשתי אוספים נפרדים, אלה שנמדדים
ואלה שלא.
וברגע שעשינו את זה, אנחנו חוזרים לשיטה
שרק תיארתי, וככה מדידות למערכות קוונטיות מרובות עובדות.
ועכשיו לסיום, נעבור לפעולות אוניטריות
על מערכות מרובות.
באמצעות אותו רעיון בסיסי שמערכות מרובות ניתנות לראייה כמערכות מורכבות בודדות.
אנחנו מסיקים את מה שרואים
כתוב כאן על המסך, פעולות קוונטיות על מערכות מורכבות מיוצגות על ידי מטריצות אוניטריות
בדיוק כמו שיש לנו למערכות בודדות וספציפית השורות והעמודות של אותן מטריצות אוניטריות מתאימות למכפלה הקרטזית
של קבוצות המצבים הקלאסיות של כל אוסף
מערכות שאנחנו מדברים עליו.
לדוגמה, אם יש לנו מערכת X
שהמצבים הקלאסיים שלה הם אחד, שתיים ושלוש ו-Y הוא qubit,
אז המטריצה שרואים כאן היא דוגמה של מטריצה אוניטרית שמייצגת
פעולה על הזוג XY.
הפרטים של איך אנחנו
מסדרים מכפלות קרטזיות שדיברנו עליהם קודם לא ממש משנים לצורך
הדוגמה הזו, זו סתם מטריצה שש על שש
שבמקרה אוניטרית.
אין בה שום דבר מיוחד, למרות שהיא בנויה מכמה
מטריצות חשובות.
הנקודה היא שאפשר
לבחור כל מטריצה אוניטרית שש על שש והיא תייצג
פעולה אוניטרית על XY.
אם אנחנו מפעילים אוסף של
פעולות אוניטריות באופן עצמאי כל אחת על המערכת שלה, אז הפעולה של כולן ביחד
על המערכת המורכבת ניתנת
על ידי המכפלה הטנזורית.
וכאן על המסך אפשר לראות ניסוח מדויק יותר
של העובדה הזו.
אם הפעולות האוניטריות שלנו מתוארות על ידי המטריצות האוניטריות U1 עד Un אחת לכל אחת מהמערכות שלנו,
אז הפעולה המשולבת
על המערכת המורכבת ניתנת על ידי המכפלה
הטנזורית של U1 עד Un.
שוב, בדומה למה שהיה לנו בהקשר ההסתברותי, דוגמה חשובה היא
שאנחנו מפעילים פעולה אוניטרית כלשהי
U על מערכת X ולא עושים
כלום למערכת אחרת Y.
הפעולה על XY שנקבל היא U בטנזור עם מטריצת היחידה.
מטריצת היחידה
מתארת עשיית כלום ל-Y.
לפעמים מועיל לכתוב באופן מפורש שמטריצת היחידה הזו
מתאימה למערכת Y, רק כדי לעשות את הנוסחאות יותר ברורות.
ואפשרות אחת היא
לתת למטריצת היחידה אינדקס תחתון ככה שמציין את המערכת שהיא פועלת עליה.
כשזה ברור מספיק, בדרך כלל אנחנו לא
טורחים עם אינדקס תחתון, אבל כשדברים נהיים יותר מסובכים, זה יכול להיות מאוד מועיל.
ואפשר גם לשקול
את המקרה הסימטרי שבו פעולה אוניטרית
כלשהי V מופעלת על Y ולא עושים כלום ל-X,
והפעם הפעולה האוניטרית
המתקבלת על XY, מיוצגת על ידי המכפלה
הטנזורית הזו כאן.
ושוב, אפשר לשים אינדקס תחתון על
מטריצת היחידה אם זה עוזר.
הנה כמה דוגמאות ספציפיות.
אם X ו-Y הם qubit-ים ואנחנו
מבצעים פעולת Hadamard על X ולא עושים כלום ל-Y, נקבל את המטריצה שרואים כאן.
אם מצד שני, אנחנו מבצעים את פעולת ה-Hadamard על Y ולא עושים כלום ל-X, הסדר של המכפלה
הטנזורית מתהפך.
ואז נקבל את המטריצה
שרואים כאן.
לא כל פעולה אוניטרית
על מערכת מורכבת ניתנת לביטוי כמכפלה טנזורית.
אם יש לנו מכפלה טנזורית,
אז יש לנו אי-תלות.
ויש כמה דוגמאות
די יסודיות של פעולות שבהחלט
לא פועלות באופן עצמאי על מערכות מרובות.
לדוגמה, אם ל-X ול-Y יש
את אותה קבוצת מצבים קלאסית, שיכולה להיות כל
קבוצת מצבים קלאסית סיגמא,
אז אפשר לחשוב על
פעולת ההחלפה על הזוג XY.
הפעולה הזו לא משנה את הסדר של שתי המערכות, עדיין יש לנו את X בצד
שמאל ו-Y בצד ימין, אלא היא מייצגת
החלפת התוכן
של שתי המערכות. כאן אפשר לראות את זה מבוטא
בצורת משוואה שבה יש מכפלה
טנזורית של שני מצבים קוונטיים.
דרך אחרת לכתוב את זה היא
כמטריצה כמו שרואים כאן.
אפשר לחשוב על
התיאור הזה ככזה שאומר לנו מה קורה עבור וקטורי בסיס סטנדרטי.
וברגע שאנחנו יודעים מה קורה
עבור וקטורי בסיס סטנדרטי, אנחנו יודעים מה קורה עבור
מצבים קוונטיים שרירותיים על ידי ליניאריות,
שלמעשה זה נכון גם לגבי
הביטוי הזה כאן.
אז הפעולה הספציפית הזו כאן היא גם פעולה דטרמיניסטית וגם פעולה אוניטרית.
אם X ו-Y הם qubit-ים, למשל, נקבל את הייצוג
המטריצי הזה כאן.
הנה קשר מעניין
בין פעולת ההחלפה וארבעת מצבי Bell, שמוצגים כאן
לנוחות.
פעולת ההחלפה משאירה את
שלושת הראשונים ללא שינוי, אבל היא שמה סימן מינוס לפני
מצב Psi מינוס,
אז יש משהו
מיוחד בזה.
אפשר לבדוק את המשוואות האלה ישירות על ידי הסתכלות על הוקטורים האלה ושקילת מה קורה
עבור מצבי הבסיס הסטנדרטי
החלפת שני המצבים הקלאסיים עבור שלושת מצבי Bell
הראשונים לא עושה כלום אנחנו מקבלים את אותו מצב שהתחלנו איתו.
אבל במקרה הרביעי, סימן המינוס למעשה
עובר מאיבר אחד לאחר כשאנחנו מבצעים את ההחלפה של המצבים הקלאסיים,
וזה שקול להכפלת הוקטור במינוס אחד.
אז ביצוע פעולת ההחלפה איכשהו מוציא סימן מינוס
ממצב Bell הרביעי.
יהיה לנו עוד מה לומר על
המשוואות האלה בהמשך, אבל עכשיו בואו נעבור לסוג
אחר של פעולה, שהיא פעולה מבוקרת.
אנחנו הולכים להניח ש-X הוא qubit ו-Y הוא כל מערכת שתרצו.
אם U היא פעולה אוניטרית על Y, אז פעולת U מבוקרת על XY היא הפעולה שמבוטאת
כאן.
קודם, באמצעות סימון דיראק ואז באמצעות מה שנקרא
מטריצת בלוקים אתם פשוט מדמיינים מילוי
של המטריצה הגדולה הזו
עם הקטנות כאשר האפסים האלה באמת מייצגים מטריצות
מלאות באפסים.
אז כל אחד מארבעת הבלוקים האלה מייצג מטריצה עם מספר
שורות ועמודות שמתאים למספר
המצבים הקלאסיים של Y.
הרעיון של פעולה מבוקרת, שכבר פגשנו
בהקשר הקלאסי כשדנו בפעולת
NOT מבוקרת,
הוא שאם X מוגדר לאפס,
אז כלום לא קורה ל-Y.
אבל אם X מוגדר לאחד,
אז U מופעלת על Y.
אז X נקרא ה-qubit הבקרה, ו-Y נקרא מערכת המטרה, שבאופן כללי לא
חייבת להיות qubit.
לדוגמה ספציפית,
שרק הזכרתי, יש לנו פעולת NOT מבוקרת.
אם ה-qubit הראשון מוגדר
לאפס, כלום לא קורה. ואם ה-qubit הראשון מוגדר לאחד, אז פעולת NOT או שקול לכך,
פעולת סיגמא X מופעלת
על ה-qubit השני.
והנה הייצוג המטריצי שלה.
אנחנו מדברים על שני qubit-ים כאן, אז אפשר באותה מידה
להחליט שה-qubit השני הוא הבקרה והראשון
הוא המטרה.
כדי לתאר את הפעולה הזו, אנחנו פשוט מחליפים את הסדר
במכפלה הטנזורית, והתוצאה היא המטריצה
שרואים כאן.
אם במקום פעולת NOT מבוקרת, אנחנו שוקלים פעולת סיגמא
Z מבוקרת או פעולת Z מבוקרת.
נקבל את הייצוג
המטריצי הזה כאן. ובפעולה הזו, לא ממש משנה
מי הבקרה ומי המטרה.
נקבל את אותה תוצאה בכל מקרה.
אפשר ללכת עוד ולשקול פעולת החלפה מבוקרת.
וכאן אנחנו מדברים
על החלפת שני qubit-ים, אז נגיע לשלושה qubit-ים כשנכלול את ה-qubit הבקרה.
הייצוג המטריצי
נראה ככה.
זו פעולה מיוחדת למדי והיא ידועה כפעולת Fredkin, או יותר נפוץ Fredkin gate.
כשאנחנו חושבים עליה
כ-gate ב-circuit, נדון ב-circuit-ים בשיעור הבא.
הדוגמה האחרונה היא פעולת
NOT מבוקרת-מבוקרת, שהיא שוב
פעולה על שלושה qubit-ים.
והנה הייצוג המטריצי שלה. הפעולה הזו ידועה הרבה יותר
כפעולת Toffoli או Toffoli gate.
נדון בה עוד
ונראה למה גם היא וגם פעולת Fredkin הן פעולות
חשובות מאוד בשיעור מאוחר יותר.
וזהו סוף השיעור השני. בשיעור הזה, דנו באיך מידע קוונטי עובד למערכות מרובות.
אני מקווה שתצטרפו אליי
בקרוב לשיעור השלישי, שהוא על circuit-ים קוונטיים
פרוטוקולים ומשחקים.
ביי עד אז.